Kevin Cyrilla joins us now he's the
chief Washington correspondent for
Bloomberg News he's also the anchor of
Bloomberg radios sound on Kevin good
morning
we know that the Democratic lawmakers
are basically saying the Attorney
General is playing politics how are
Republicans reacting to them they are
defending the Attorney General William
bar and they are saying that this
investigation into the investigation is
something that is needed but the
question becomes whether or not House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi is going to hold a
vote in the House of Representatives
that would find him in content of
Congress now in that interview his first
interview Attorney General Barr says
that it's just political theater what
about is what are the chances now that
Muller is gonna testify how was that
looking well that is looking
increasingly like Democrats are not
going to let that particular point go
and I got to be honest up on Capitol
Hill or down on Capitol Hill I talked
about publicans who say that they
quietly would like to hear him testify
as well because so many people want to
hear from him yeah yeah well what we
heard this week right Friday as we just
old us that the president plan to lift
those metal imports the tariffs on those
but just how much arm-twisting went into
that so much I mean look Senate Finance
Committee Chairman Chuck Grassley a
Republican from Iowa which is directly
impacted by this essentially said that
us MCA or NAFTA 2.0 would be dead on
arrival if the steel and aluminum
tariffs were not list lifted now senator
Grassley is saying that he is much more
receptive to the idea of getting this
through I also spoke with senator Joni
Ernst a Republican from Iowa earlier
this week and she applauded the
president's decision on this as did
Republicans senator Marsha Blackburn
they don't like tariffs but if you look
at the geopolitical landscape in the
house it's very different because the
Democratic controlled house they make
the case that this is not progressive
enough that it doesn't have
environmental protections or worker
protections so the optimism coming in
NAFTA 2.0 is very different but trending
in a different direction than us trying
to trade talks I'm just gonna say that's
one trade battle we have the other one
with China where do we go from here when
you look forward especially to the June
g20 summit well President Trump and
President Xi Jingping of China are set
to meet in Osaka Japan
June 28th June 29th at this summit
Treasury secretary Stephen minuchin
testified on Capitol Hill earlier this
week and I briefly caught up with him
after the hearing and I asked him the
status of the talks and he said that
he's going to be headed to Beijing to
meet with Chinese vice premier Liu a hua
in order to continue these types of
trade negotiations but again a lot of
Republicans are very uneasy just about
the economic impact that this is going
to be having on supply chains on
businesses on on a host of other jobs in
their districts in particular and the
final point that I would quickly make is
that the President signed an executive
order this week that would restrict US
businesses from doing business with
Chinese telecommunications firms Huawei
and ZTE and that's a rare non partisan
issue
I interviewed Senator Mark Warner a
Democrat from Virginia on the inside
committee and he applauded the President
on that yeah it's like little fires put
out there's still a much bigger fire
blazing Kevin sir Lee thank you thank
you very much